- When you meet someone
for the first time,
what's the first thing you look at?
First couple of seconds of meeting them.
- Their face.
- Their face?
- I guess, their eyes.
- Let's be honest here.
- Eyes.
- It's the eyes?
- Their style.
- The eyes.
- What is about the eyes that--
- Whether they're alive or not.
- Oh!
First couple seconds.
- Their eyes.
- Their eyes!
- Their eyes?
- So it seems like most people
claim to look at eyes first.
I don't know if I believe that.
We're going to go back to
the office, test it out.
See if it's true.
Alright, now we're back at the office.
I'm going grab Yessica and we're going to
get going on an experiment to find out
what people actually do look at
when they first meet someone.
So step one, we need to hire some humans
and shoot footage of
them walking, talking,
looking into the camera,
and getting undressed.
You know, human stuff.
Then we set up eye motions
and an eye tracking software
and bring in our coworkers
to check out the footage.
- You looking at her face,
looking at their faces.
- Those eyeballs.
- As they watch this odd video, we will
record every movement of their eyes.
When we watch the analysis back
and search for patterns, we
found some unexpected results.
The first was that ladies and dudes
seemed to check out boobs the same amount.
Yeah, dudes thought they'd
probably glance at breasts.
- At least with women,
I'm definitely looking
at you know, like, you know, breasts.
- She's wearing an open shirt.
Where are you supposed to look?
- Then like the deep V?
- But women dig boobs too.
- Oh woah, that is a deeply cut shirt.
- And the second super surprising result
was that even with all the accessories,
boob, dicks and all the distractions,
they're all in the frame, we
still look at faces the most.
And not just eyes as many
thought but the whole face.
But why do we do this?
Is it to be polite?
Is it because eyes are
the window to the soul?
Nope.
Research actually hypothesizes
that we look at faces first
because we're programmed to find faces.
In fact, look what happens
when we show people
this picture of pasta.
We find the face even in
this inanimate picture.
And this picture.
And this one too.
This is because as social creatures,
our ability to quickly find a face
and determine if it was friendly or not
kept our ancestors alive.
Today those same skills help us
navigate our complex social world
of group hangs and Tinder dates.
So people were kind of right.
We do look at eyes first.
But it's only because we're hard wired
to find and interpret faces.
- That's some cool science for you.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
- Cool.
- Yeah, cool.
- Science.
- Cool science.